se voi foste tutti i pennuti mi è
piaciuta molto la speaker che abbiamo
visto in video prima se voi foste tutti
i pennuti questa storia vi piacerebbe
queste sono le mie mani quando avevo 14
anni
un'estate al mare i miei genitori
affittarono un appartamento con una
grande terrazza e su questa terrazza
subito il primo giorno trovammo un nido
caduto da chissà dove con dentro quattro
piccoli uccellini moribondi schiumati
malconci e pensiamo io e mio fratello di
chiedere ai nostri genitori ci potevamo
provare ad allevarli a farli crescere
non sapevamo come fare e pensammo di
nutrirli con riso soffiato bagnato nel
latte è contro ogni previsione
gli uccellini kreiber diventarono più
grandi le loro piume divennero più folte
e dopo un po iniziarono a muoversi per
casa come se fossero dei cuccioli di una
specie di qualunque è questa storia mi
piace tantissimo me la porto dietro da
un sacco di tempo e ogni tanto penso che
potrei venderla ad una societa che
produce cereali
ho anche già in mente lo slogan il riso
soffiato ti mette le ali
però se io ve la dico così a voi ne
viene in mente un altro di slogan e
funziona così è dentro ognuno di noi ci
sono un sacco di storie già scritte se
ci dicono l'inizio ci viene in mente la
fine
se io vi dico rosso di sera voi pensate
bel tempo si spera tante piccolissime
storie che ci aiutano ad orientarci
nella vita
io ad esempio credo che chiusa una porta
si apre un portone che non c'è due senza
tre e che tanto va la gatta al lardo che
ci lascia lo zampino anche se questa non
mi è mai stata del tutto chiara
però non credo soltanto alle storie io
credo ad esempio che cappuccetto rosso e
la nonna escano dalla pancia del lupo
inter e credo che presto
avremo un presidente della repubblica
donna
credo che l'olio di palma stia dentro le
palme su questo non mi sono ancora fatto
neither chiarissima le storie insegnano
io imparo dalle storie tutti impariamo
dalle storie impariamo provando e
sbagliando impariamo guardando gli altri
che provano e sbagliano anche che hanno
grandi successi si chiama esperienza
testimoniale ma gli esseri umani
imparano anche dalle storie per noi le
storie sono simulatori di volo per
questo dentro ci mettiamo tutte le
informazioni che ci sembrano importanti
utili quelle che devono attraversare il
tempo e lo spazio tipo non andare nel
bosco di sera non scambiare la tua mucca
per 4 fagioli non gridare al lupo al
lupo ma anche quando raccontiamo le
nostre esperienze di vita
cerchiamo di metterci dentro delle
informazioni che siano utili all'altro
cerchiamo di consegnargli delle
istruzioni una morale quando il 2 luglio
del 2015
la mia vita è cambiata completamente
e stato subito di una morale che mi sono
messa in cerca vi racconto come è andata
era il giorno dopo il mio quarantesimo
compleanno
ero in ufficio con i miei colleghi in
una grande stanza stavamo festeggiando
avevo portato un po di pasticcini e a un
certo punto mi sono accorta di aver
dimenticato in stanza qualcosa e quindi
sono tornata indietro
entrando nella mia stanza ho visto il
mio cellulare che squillava sulla
scrivania con un numero sconosciuto era
il mio compleanno
qualcuno voleva farmi gli auguri e
quindi prendo il telefono è una voce da
chirurga dall'altro lato mi dice sei
seduta
chissà perché ci chiedono sempre se
siamo seduti come se da una sedia non si
potesse cadere
comunque la scena era questa la
bottiglia di spumante in una mano il
telefono nell'altra ok e io dico
sono seduta ok allora dobbiamo parlare
il neo che ti abbiamo tolto qualche
giorno fa era un brutto melanoma e
dobbiamo operare con urgenza dobbiamo
capire quanto a fondo possa essere
entrato e dovremo anche togliere il
linfonodo sentinella per vedere se ci
sono metastasi di tutte quelle parole io
avevo capito solo sentinella è però mi
source e subito il dubbio che non si
trattava di un soldato sulla torretta di
controllo del fortino fu il primo
indizio del fatto che avevo smesso di
capire di capire qualunque cosa è
proprio tutto
non ho ancora le parole per spiegare il
senso di niente che mi pervase di
recente qualcuno mi ha spiegato che è
l'effetto dello shock la mente si
protegge e come si svenisse smette di
percepire avessi dovuto dirlo con parole
mie
avrei parlato di un enorme tappo da
qualche parte nella testa o nella pancia
non entrava nulla danno estetico
intervento demolitivo invalidità
permanente niente potremmo riassumere
questo momento in era una notte buia e
tempestosa quando pian piano ho iniziato
a mettere insieme dei pezzi ho stilato
un elenco variabile delle cose capite
primo finché c'è qualcosa da fare
falla secondo vale tutto vale chi ti
chiama cento volte e chi non ti chiama
mai perché non sa che cosa dire
e questa si chiama assoluzione terzo non
è mai la paura che arriva per prima
prima arriva il racconto della paura
la mente cosa fa si mette lì e sfoglia
un lungo catalogo di paure già vissute o
sentite raccontare che li so il buio il
fuoco il cadere cerca per appostazione
mettere insieme tutto quello che ha
messo sul capitolo paura di farsi
un'idea della realtà e di teste
una trama probabilistica sul futuro su
come andrà a finire
io non avevo una storia per la parola
melanoma non l'avevo mai incontrata sì
avevo letto distrattamente qualche
articolo d'estate ma non conoscevo
nessuno che l'avesse avuta la parola
cancro però una storia l'aveva e io
finivo con link ai armi in quella perché
è successo perché a me come andrà a
finire
e soprattutto qual è la morale di questa
storia
noi andiamo in cerca di morale e di
significati e quando i significati ti
mancano che cosa fai vai su internet mi
ritroverò delle risposte le informazioni
che mi mancano non sto capendo apro
internet non fate quelle facce adesso lo
so anch'io che non è stata una buona
idea forse conoscete una teoria che dice
che noi condividiamo molto più spesso le
esperienze negative di quelle positive
non lo so bene perché lo facciamo ma ne
ho una mia di teoria riguardo che si
rifà i proverbi di prima
noi siamo quelli del mal comune mezzo
gaudio ci pare brutto dire che le cose
vanno bene le diciamo non ne vale la
pena
misuriamo in pena il valore delle cose e
quindi io che ero in cerca di di piccole
storie positive io non cercavo è storia
a lieto fine o ancora otto anni e mezzo
di controlli davanti lunga la strada
prima di dirmi salva
cercavo storie divieto decorso cercavo
qualcuno che mi permettesse di
apprendere la speranza raccontandomi la
sua io avevo bisogno di poco e avevo
bisogno che mi dicessero come mi dovevo
vestire ora che il mio corpo era un po
diverso dopo tre interventi perché nel
mio caso le metastasi c'erano e quindi
avevamo dovuto fare un pò le robe di
corsa e qualcuno che mi dicesse che le
cicatrici prima o poi si sarebbero un po
sbiadite che mi raccontasse che sarei
tornata a ballare magari poco magari
sono i lenti magari lenti da seduta
datemi qualcosa e allora e lì è stato in
quel momento lì che io ho capito come la
mia esperienza di studiosa racconta
storie poteva tornarmi utile presi
l'impegno con me stessa che per tenere
un po impegnato alla mente di iniziare a
raccontare storie divieto decorso e devo
dire che fino a oggi ha funzionato
io scrivo storie racconto storie insegnò
agli altri a raccontare storie
chi come me si occupa di narrazione sa
che nelle storie il dolore la rottura
all'incidente ce lo devi mettere perché
fanno parte della vita sano la storia
non è credibile
ma quando il dolore è dato bisogna
prendersi la responsabilità nella storia
di metterci un po di luce un po di
speranza perché qualcuno che riceve oggi
la diagnosi di fu una brutta malattia
possa fare in internet trovare un
qualcosa a cui aggrapparsi io all'epoca
non lo conoscevo giovanni lo speaker di
prima se no mi sarei sentita un po
meglio a mi sono sempre state le storie
a mettere le ali adesso l'ho lasciato lì
i miei uccellini perché volevo
raccontarvi come è andata a finire
una mattina eravamo in casa sentimmo
cinguettare molto forte e uscimmo tutti
quanti sul terrazzo per vedere che cosa
stesse succedendo a un uccello più
grande da noi subito battezzato la mamma
era sul tetto della casa e chiamava a
raccolta i nostri cellini loro frenetici
correvano per il terrazzo e andarono a
mettersi in fila sul bordo del balcone
in uno slancio di entusiasmo si
lanciarono nel vuoto e caddero nel
giardino di sotto io mio fratello di
corsa andammo recuperarli sperando di
trovarli tutti interi stavano benissimo
lì prendemmo e li riportiamo sul
terrazzo però loro ancora presi da quel
fremito si riportarono sul board e si
lanciarono in aria ricadendo di nuovo di
sotto ma è stata la terza volta come
nelle migliori favole
che quando siamo andati a prenderli e li
abbiamo riportati sul terrazzo loro
tranquilli sono tornati sul bordo e si
sono lanciati hanno spiccato il volo
ecco io sono sicura che tutti noi
io ho di certo abbiamo imparato quel
giorno
che cos'è la speranza grazie a tutti
[Applauso]